I always envisioned myself Neil being a
rapper and being in the game and having
success but you never know what it
really feels like how you're going to be
when you're there I don't think either
of my parents you know thought that I
was going to go take it this far I see
myself as a pioneer and again that's the
main thing I don't really do too many
campaigns like make people do stuff like
gimmicks or anything I just try to give
him as much as possible Shawn the love
he's an American rapper songwriter and
actor he received numerous awards even
before he launched his career and debut
album including being one of Rolling
Stones artists to watch his debut single
black and yellow hit number one on the
Billboard Hot 100 he's Wiz Khalifa and
here is my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number two is my personal
favorite and I'm curious if your girl
which one you guys like the best and as
always if Wiz is talking and says
something really inspiring to you please
leave in the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
away
I do yeah I do
screaming master when I hold on the
you see me you know a day hello got a
yellow
I have been making music and writing and
freestyling with my cousins and stuff
like that like rapping over other
people's beats but I guess I just got to
that point where I was comfortable and I
was really really out of passion for
someone I told my dad he's like if you
want to do it then do it I don't think
either of my parents you know thought
that I was going to go take it this far
but on they supported me to never fit
made me feel like it was out of reach
and I'm when it happened it was you know
dream come true I had a dream that the
whole world was staring at me I woke up
there was no one there wasn't no one
same song the only time I would lose is
if I give up Who I am you know what I'm
saying and as long as I stand up for me
and what I believe in I'll be straight I
see myself as a pioneer in the game I
see Drake as a pioneer and again people
like little Wayne and there's only sort
of people who who really come and define
your generation other than being part of
their generation and it's cool to be a
part of it as well
but this is how I see myself as a leader
and somebody who changes things and
doesn't just follow my crowd that
everybody that I talked to that they
either dress weird smoke weed you know
Drive certain cars escape and it's like
I've done all of these things and I've
been into all of these things and I've
learned them in different stages of my
life and it's just a minute stage right
now it's like I really want to do
something physical I got a son on the
way you know what I'm saying and I'm
learning how to skate it's like
something I always wanted to do but with
rapping and making money and provide for
a family and stuff like that you want to
always get the time to just grab a board
and go skate so I kind of did it in
Reverse but it's something I'm really
passionate about just it's just
passionate by having fun with it I don't
want to be the best skater in the world
I just want to like you know be able to
relax and cruise so no judging from the
pictures you're also not afraid to take
a fall throughout you can't be you can't
be man you're gonna take some Falls that
I had my chin that's cool now like so am
I and like being that I'm on TV and I
everybody's like don't do this you want
to get hurry one get that but you know
you got everything is a risk you know
what I'm saying so if you're not willing
to take the risk and there's no point in
doing it anyway
where did you kind of decide to toe the
line cuz like in the UK the problem is a
lot of white is released a lot of free
material and then when it comes to like
sort of retailing their material
he's like people still expect the free
stuff how was it for you to transition
um well you just got to make a
difference between what the free stuff
is and what the what the stuff for sale
is and when you polish it up and when
you give them great free music and great
free stuff to a point where it's like
you know they want to pay for it like
when I put on my mixtapes I use all
original beats and I'm put so much
thought and so much stuff into them
people are like you know I'm gonna buy
the album like you know that's just they
feel like that's their job so I think
it's just making people feel involved
and and they want to support and that's
the that's the main thing I don't really
do too many campaigns like make people
do stuff for like gimmicks or anything I
just try to give them as much as
possible show them the love and then if
they want to support that's what they do
[Music]
I always envisioned myself and Neil
being a rapper and being in the game and
having success but you never know what
it really feels like how you're going to
be when you're there
[Music]
[Applause]
and then which comes from me being the
youngest dude in my age group of people
that hung out with it would call me a
young whiz you know like always wise
beyond my years and the Khalifa is
Arabic at me and successor leader
shining light my granddad gave me that
name he's um actually Muslim so you know
he's to see my path and when I was doing
it how hard I was working and he gave me
that name and I just put the two
together
Oh
of course I do rap music and I'm a
hip-hop artist but as an individual as a
personality and what I give to people I
see myself as like the lead singer of a
band or something
you know when I go out there I'm a real
performer it's all about the vibe in the
feeling you got to be balanced and it's
like nothing that I have to put on I
really feel you know that energetic and
that happy to be in front of the kids
I've actually had new management for a
past like year and a half almost I
didn't sign with um constant sports and
smack Entertainment and it's been really
good cuz she doesn't even do rap they
just used to work with snoop back in the
day but she does people like Michael
Strahan and Tony Gonzales and Deion
Sanders and stuff like that so um when
she took me under her wing and started
managing me it was it was really good
because it was it allowed me to go to
the next level and for people to look at
me like I was doing bigger and better
things um and my relationship with my
old business partners and things like
that it's like it just it comes to a
point where you know I started really
early with them when I was 16 I'm 28 now
and it's like you know things change
so um throughout that time I just had to
boss up and man up and do my own thing
and some people are with that some
people aren't with that and it's
sometimes as easy sometimes is not part
of bossing up is you know proving that
you're a boss so that's what we're going
through now I will teach how to be your
own boss they really don't teach you
that much in school make it like
entrepreneurship classes and stuff like
that but they don't really teach you how
to be your own boss so I would like try
to teach kids I don't like really really
work for themselves build the
relationships with people inside the
game whether it be DJs or radio or promo
people and just got our interviews or
whoever because you you meet and you
always want to work with these people
throughout your career
and whether you're doing good or bad
they're always gonna remember you and
you want them to you know want you to do
well you will caught yes sir I was that
touring studio yeah touring all the time
um that that came up more recently you
know my tours were a little bit more
spread out before but now I'm pretty
much always moving always on the go yeah
this is about November up in love with
that heat baby yeah exactly it's full-up
exactly you know I'm always record about
I built a studio my house um I got
studio buses on the road and stuff like
that so I'm always putting I'm not
leaving it I'm gonna be here forever so
that's what people can expect there
would be an old-ass man my hair gonna be
down here is gonna be great and when I
feel like leaving then that's what I'm
gonna do but about 180 years I plan on
sticking around
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because 50 cent Uruguay
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want made a
profile next leave in comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the rules had the biggest
impact on you and why what did you learn
from watching this video super curious
to find out please put it in the
comments below and they also want to
give a quick shout out to Justin Morgan
mr. new future builder thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book and
that amazing YouTube unboxing video that
you made it really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you enjoy man your
one word ever Carmichael thank you
waiting for this way for a while for
this order this a long time long long
time ago the moment that he announced
that pre-orders were available I'm
pretty much hopped on this a couple
weeks after that and so your one word so
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon